madame bora de la mairie de saint rémy
l'honorer au palais du luxembourg il n'y
a qu'un pas pour toi de bora à 51 ans la
maire de cette commune est devenue
sénatrice des yvelines le 1er octobre
2020 c'est un honneur une fierté d'y
siéger de siéger au palais du luxembourg
de représenter d'être au service de mon
pays
toine bourg a obtenu ce nouveau mandat
suite à la démission d'alain schmitz
sénateur depuis 2010 est l ancien
président du conseil général de 2009 à
2014 a décidé de prendre du recul avec
la politique
je veux dire que la chemise se fait un
travail tout à fait exceptionnelle aux
seniors en métaux il a été extrêmement
proche des communes des yvelines c'est
ça notre équilibre permanent ont trouvé
entre la réalité du territoire dans sa
diversité territoire français dans sa
diversité aussi se nourrir de nos
expériences locales pour enrichir les
textes nationaux dans cet équilibre
thuan bora siégera au sein de la
commission culture éducation et
communication aux côtés de son collègue
michel laugier tout en conservant cet
ancrage local essentiel dans le mandat
de sénateur je souhaite être une
sénatrice active à l'écouté des élus une
sénatrice qui défendra les territoires
si on pouvait aller j'ai les choses afin
que les maires puissent être plus
efficace et plus réactif ce sera pour
moi une très grande chose évidemment
réforme de la décentralisation le plan
de relance ou encore la fiscalité locale
pour 2021 les prochains dossiers sur
lesquels vont se pencher les 348
parlementaires du palais du luxembourg
dont la nouvelle sénatrice des yvelines
thuan bourges